the last time a human set foot on the
moon was in december
of 1972 during the apollo 17 mission
and at the rate that moon missions are
progressing today
it's no question that we'll cross the 50
year mark with
no manned moon missions with mars you
could say that it's extremely hard in a
variety of different realms
and this applies to the moon as well but
the key difference between the two
is that we've already been to the moon
several times
so why did we ditch the moon for half a
century
[Music]
well the first and most obvious reason
is of course
budgetary restrictions in 2005
nasa estimated that it would cost 104
billion dollars to get people back to
the moon which is the same
as 133 billion dollars today
this is actually not too bad and
nasa could very well accomplish this
over 10
to 15 years if they devoted about half
of their 20 billion
annual budget towards the moon however
nasa's responsibilities
are far greater than simply sending
manned exploration
and colonization missions to outer space
for instance
they have to split this funding among
the james webb space telescope
developing their new rocket called space
launch system and
sending rovers and probes to other
planets their moons
the sun and even outside the solar
system due to nasa's wide focus
they are unable to devote so much
capital towards putting people
back on the moon also it's not like nasa
is
just burning through cash they have
actually significantly
increased their efficiency since the
1960s and 70s
as they should throughout the 60s and
70s the apollo program
cost 25.8 billion dollars which
is the same as 264 billion today
considering that their new estimate is
just half of that
at 133 billion they have no doubt
made some serious progress even if they
were to overrun the budget to
150 or 160 billion but
this does raise a different concern how
are they able to fund 264 billion
dollars in the 1960s
but they can't fund just half of that
over the next
50 years well as you guys probably
already knew
nasa's budget has been getting slashed
for decades at this point
and it's far worse than you probably
expected
as we are often shown budget numbers in
the 20 plus
billion range making us think that it's
actually
not that bad but here's the thing they
received a solid 4.5 percent
of the federal budget in relation to
today's 4.79 trillion dollar budget
that's the same as nasa receiving 215
billion dollars per year
or about 10 times what they actually
receive today
of course that might not make sense
today
but even just half of that would still
be 100 billion dollars
which would give nasa much more liberty
in
actually pushing forward space
technology however
this is very unlikely to happen because
of one major limitation
which is public support and i'm not just
talking about a lack of enthusiasm or
energy
that we saw in the 1960s and 70s
though we and our little community here
on youtube
are eager to get people back to the moon
and mars
this is not the case with the average
american 42.9
of americans straight up opposed nasa
returning to the moon with humans
because they don't believe that it is a
priority at this time
and another 19.2 believe that we should
simply send robots back
considering this only a little over a
third of americans
support the idea of nasa returning to
the moon with humans
in the imminent future this isn't
necessarily because the average american
isn't excited about space rather they
simply believe
that mars is the next logical step as
it's estimated that 63
of americans support a crude mars
mission and
this of course brings us into politics
now
i'm not talking about political benefit
like with mars
but rather political risk with mars
there is no political benefit as the
mission would take
10 plus years so it wouldn't help the
candidate's political campaign
with the moon on the other hand a
mission could be completed within one
term
especially if you build off of the
previous president's space proposal
instead of scrapping it all together
like we have seen time
and time again but politicians shy away
from this prospect due to political risk
carrying out a moon mission is evidently
very dangerous
and could go wrong and if it does
well this is not the best look for the
president's reelection campaign
but wait a minute don't presidents take
such risks all the time
in order to potentially boost political
support we're going to build a wall
it's going to be built while this is
true
the issue with a manned mission to the
moon is that the political risk to
benefit
is simply not worth it because we've
already gone to the moon
since we've already gone to the moon six
times going to the moon at seventh time
wouldn't really be a wow moment for the
average person
this is actually starting to change now
as we haven't returned to the moon
in nearly 50 years which has started a
new interest
in the moon however that was not the
case
through most of the 70s 80s and even 90s
getting to the moon wouldn't win over
that much political support
while failing to get there would reflect
poorly on the administration
but even more importantly in my opinion
the biggest reason we haven't returned
to moon
is that the ussr is no more we often
like to think that we would have
eventually gone to the moon
without the space race or the cold war
due to our instinctive yearning to
explore
and advance ourselves but if this was
really true
i think we'd agree that we would already
have humans
on mars so though it doesn't sound so
wholesome i believe the key to putting
men on the moon
so early on is almost single-handedly
the ussr
and it's not just a case of oh we're not
pushing ourselves as much
because we don't have competition this
isn't necessarily true
as the moon wasn't the result of healthy
competition
but rather unhealthy competition you see
the traits of healthy competition are
pushing for the entire field
furthering personal potential honoring
mutually held values
and valuing the journey just as much as
the outcome
in the case of the space race healthy
competition would entail projects such
as the international space station
the space shuttle program the current
race to colonize the moon
and the current race to colonize mars
but
you'd be kidding yourself if you think
that the apollo program was bred with
healthy competition
as it was basically a definition of
unhealthy competition
the traits of unhealthy competition
include scarcity
and fear seeking validation and
attention
putting down others and most importantly
winning
no matter the cost starting with
scarcity and fear
the apollo program was started during
the height of the cold war
during which the fear of nuclear war was
at all time highs
as a result the plan to put humans on
the moon
was more of a response to the ussr
succeeding in putting humans
in orbit and the fear that they would
likewise leave behind the us
in terms of space technology in general
moving on to validation and attention
the us
was seeking validation and attention
from countries around the world
but this wasn't really for the
revolutionary scientific feat
if that was the case it wouldn't
actually be unhealthy competition
rather the validation and attention the
u.s was seeking
was for their economic and political
power that made such a revolutionary
scientific feat
possible in other words they were trying
to prove the superiority
of a capitalist society and this of
course
goes along with putting down others as
the us
was putting down socialist countries in
the process of boasting their own system
lastly as for winning at all costs
well this was basically nasa's motto
we've all heard the famous quote
failure is not an option this is a
phenomenal approach when dealing with
code missions
as failure should not be an option but
when you're trying to develop new
technology new prototypes and new ideas
this is a terrible idea finding new
innovative solutions requires trial and
error
and avoiding the stage will likely slow
and even limit progression
also something else to consider is that
maybe
it's not that nasa's budget is low today
but rather
their budget was extremely high in the
1960s
no matter how much money it took no
matter how much manpower it took
and no matter the innovations they were
sacrificing by rushing to accomplish
one narrow goal the u.s didn't care
as we strive to win no matter the cost
so for the best or the worst the initial
drive to succeed in a manned moon
mission was largely due to
unhealthy competition with the ussr
and the lack of this unhealthy
competition has
in my opinion been the key limiting
factor when it comes to returning humans
to the moon but looking forward things
are looking much better
as the scene for healthy competition is
doing better than
ever before we have spacex blue origin
virgin galactic nasa themselves and much
much more and as these companies are
participating
in a healthy competitive environment
where they are truly looking to advance
space exploration
and colonization as opposed to just
flexing national might
we may for once finally see the
timelines put out by these organizations
come true if you guys are excited for
the future of crude missions
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you